we all know that Shonda loves drama and
controversy but it is nothing compared
to what is coming out on the paramount
network with their new series Heather's
remember the 80s movie starring shannen
doherty well it's back at this time on
TV and Shannon is also back and it is
even darker than the original it is so
wild as a matter of fact so over-the-top
that some are even calling it the most
controversial TV show ever
Veronica why are you pulling just like
the 1989 high school cult classic get
ready for the portable lines in some
very controversial scenes all teachers
will be required to keep a loaded
firearm in their desk drawers at all
times I'm actually having a really great
time guns in classrooms teen suicide all
handled with biting satire you have to
do something maybe a bake sale teens
like muffins yeah art
too closely imitating life initially
spelled trouble for the show the
paramount Network pushed its spring
premiere in the wake of the Parkland
school shooting Ben in June after more
violence at a Texas school the series
was scrapped entirely but now
Heather's is back if anyone has a reason
to kill themselves it's you
it had to be re-edited some
objectionable scenes were cut and one
episode was completely dropped because
quote it's been considered too
controversial
ETS learned why the episode involved
blowing up the school a nod to the
original film is really dark and so we
definitely didn't pull any punches it is
in fact darker than they originally
people will watch and be like oh my god
is this really happening the dark comedy
will only air on TV in two episode
blocks for five consecutive nights but a
season two script has been written
so if ratings hold the Paramount Network
may say Heather's is worth more than
just a binge and purge binge it up baby
make it up baby
lick it now the finale will be followed
by the premiere of a new Heather's
themed episode of lip sync battle
you